so did you ever see that movie about
cigarettes back in the early 2000s what
was that thank you for saying thank you
thank you for smoking right so you've
seen taylor yeah yeah what a sick movie
right i mean the sick in a good way like
great action
yes and i watch it i'm like okay
first of all i can't stand cigarettes i
mean i'm i'm somebody that you know if a
salesperson comes to my house they smoke
cigarettes if that if i shake their
hands i'm not buying from them that's
just me i don't like cigarettes i've
never been a fan of cigarettes to me the
smell of cigarettes is very different
than the smell of weed the smell of
cigar there's something about cigarettes
and it's all chemicals and i mean and
that's my personal opinion some people
say i can't believe you just said that i
smoke i'm offended i it's my opinion
it's how i feel but when i watched that
movie
i sat there and i said
what a freaking great job lobbying
to convince
millions of intelligent people with
common sense
that cigarette doesn't harm you you're
just watching you're like wow what a
great job lobbyists did right
and they and then you know all the
commercials and all this and then
finally people are like listen you're
full of [ __ ] here's a lung smoking
cigarettes yeah here's one not smoking
cigarettes oh that's not the case that's
something else no no this is the reality
with anecdotal i have an uncle who lived
in 95. yeah so so then but what that
took what that took me to was
what other industry or product have we
been convinced
that's good or bad
because of brilliant men like him that
are great sales people great
communicators great persuaders who go
around
being witty sharp smart you're like oh
my god this guy knows what he's talking
about he's just kind of back down and
the average person can't you know debate
and have an inner you know interaction
with somebody at that level she's like
dude you know what i'm not even gonna
have the conversation whatever i'll
leave it alone right right so so for me
when i think about climate change i look
at both sides i try to reason i look at
both sides so on one side they're you
know shoving it down our throat like
neil tyson you know what's his name yeah
he's like well you know at this point of
the game the question isn't whether it's
happening or not there is no such thing
as anti-climate change whatever deniers
it's happening those people don't know
what they're talking about so now that
we know what's happening let's address
it right you can't even have the debate
and then the other side
you know is who wouldn't want that to
happen who who doesn't want the debate
of climate change to happen well i'm
from you know i lived in texas five
years there's a lot of oil guys that
probably don't want this to happen i
would assume that a part of elon musk
selling the fact that we have to be
careful with this is his company is
tesla so the incentive is i sell
insurance i have to sell you right what
the benefit of life insurance he sells
live settlement he's going to sell you
on what life said you have something you
sell you have to sell us on it and we
all have to persuade each other right
but there has to be some somebody that's
writing somebody that's wrong so i had
paul manafort here two weeks ago last
week maybe you know paul manafort is
yeah and he's a lobbyist you know he's
made millions of dollars just off
lobbying i'm uncomfortable with a lobby
he says well you know if they're going
to use it he's going to use it as well
fine no problem
your argument that you make one may say
mark i mean
you're from rush limbaugh's side i mean
we know where rush stood you know russia
is as right-wing and republican as he
can get he pissed off a lot of people
for 20 years
okay great fine he's a hero to many but
he's hated by many as well i mean the
hero and hate it is in the same category
meaning as far right far left both sides
some may say yeah you know you're
probably just defending your oil guys
and and people who are on your side of
the other your friends you go to parties
with them so you have to say something
like this because if something happens
those guys may use billions of dollars
so you're just helping those guys out
what do you say to people who say that i
get that all the time in fact if you go
to my about page at climate depot it
actually someone said and i can't
remember who now but some professor that
i was nick naylor in the flesh embodied
in the flesh on the climate issue
i am not a lobbyist i've never been a
lobbyist i don't lobby i don't go to i
stay as far away from dc as possible
these days but when i worked there i was
a communication director for the senate
environment and public works committee
our my organization i work for a company
called committee for constructive
tomorrow
chiefly and like when i say chiefly 85
80 90 of our money is from direct mail
to the public we are strictly grassroots
the rest of the money might come from
foundations but we do not and you can
look at my about page on wikipedia which
i have no control over they'll say that
the group we had was funded by exxon
mobil well they're very careful in their
wording i've never gotten money that i'm
aware of
with from exxon mobil exxon mobil gave
to everyone back in the day and they've
tried this it's a trick that they say
they'll say exxon mobil is given to
you know all these conservatives all
these climate denial groups and you'll
look at and they'll say they've given to
the heritage foundation they've given
the you know cato they give and a lot of
these have like five 10 15 of their
budget go to that but then you look at
it and exxon mobil gave to a lot of
liberal groups they gave a deal the
natural gas industry got gave money to
the sierra club so they could fight coal
money's like that all the way out there
but in terms of me being you know
courting fossil fuels or being a
spokesman for fossil fuels it's utter
nonsense they hate me they've hated me
they want nothing to do with me i went
time took a tour of fossil fuel guys
hatred fossil fuel yeah because they're
when i say that they may have liked me
in the 90s or something or maybe early
2000s but that they they gave up about
2004 or five long before i was even in
the senate exxonmobil announced they
were no longer giving to any groups
expressing climate you know denial or
whatever so here's the gist
they
stop giving money
and when they get when they stop giving
money they start they increase their
money the other side they just got a
grant uh it was from i want to say exxon
mobil gave to stanford university 100
million dollars to study climate change
another basic grant just came out the
largest single climate grant by an
internet billionaire and i can't
remember his name right now it was no
one not a household name gave to another
university so the money from that side
and now from corporate from the fossil
fuel to appear green
far outweighs it so i don't like that
idea at all because i i basically my
salary hasn't even changed that much on
the same scale as it was when i worked
for the u.s taxpayer in the senate so
you could argue you mentioned russian
but you could argue i'm ideologically
motivated and i think there's truth to
that everyone has an ideological
motivation i think particularly people
involved in politics
but if you go back i look at what
happens if you could even just remove
the science forget about the science and
this is what i like to do to your point
about you don't want people rush limbo
was an entertainer and i don't you know
but i'm trying to i'm trying to actually
you know
let people see the other side to this
whole issue so one of the ways i do it
i just say to hell with talking about
the science for a moment if we actually
faced a crisis nothing they've proposed
in their own words by their own methods
would have any impact on the climate and
save us in other words if we were facing
a climate catastrophe and we relied on
them for the green new deal the u.n
paris agreement carbon taxes et cetera
we would all be doomed and i can go
through and i can point to you quotes
from united nations i can point you
quotes from the epa i can cite their
studies their magic their call that's
the acronym for magic for their climate
models that show that even if we fully
committed to all this there would be no
impact pretty much on co2 emissions let
alone the climate if you actually
believe co2 was causing it so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]